Buongiorno, sono Bruna dal Brasile, e lavoro in una ong che si chiama ReCivitas.
La nostra missione è investire in persone per formare cittadini.
Sono qui per raccontare come abbiamo cambiato una vecchia e utopica idea
in una tecnologia sociale innovativa.
Un modello di politica semplice, economico e facilmente replicabile,
e con una potenza di trasformazione sociale enorme.
Nel 2007, Marcus e io ci siamo trasferiti a Paranapiacaba
per vivere e fare il nostro lavoro sociale.
Paranapiacaba è una città storica, però con molta povertà.
Questo ci ha permesso di sentire
che le persone avevano veramente bisogno di fiducia, rispetto e capitale,
e non solo di istruzione.
La rassegnazione e l'apatia erano chiari ed innegabili,
e riflettevano uno stato di depressione e di esclusione sociale.
Il problema era tale che non sapevano più cosa era accaduto.
Nessuno aveva approfittato della opportunità,
perché non avevano nessuna motivazione,
oppure, se avevano motivazione, per mancanza di opportunità.
Però, per [rompere] questo circolo vizioso,
serviva loro un progetto che non solo combattesse la povertà,
ma fosse anche in grado di promuovere la inclusione sociale.
Un processo educativo di riattivazione della fiducia
e della relazione sociale, per tutti.
Non solo rendendo disponibile a tutti ciò che è necessario
per non creare dipendenza, ma anche [facendo in modo]
che nessuno debba dipendere dagli altri.
Quindi era necessario un progetto di libertà e di emancipazione:
avevano bisogno di un reddito di cittadinanza.
Tuttavia, a quel tempo, come la maggioranza dei brasiliani,
non sapevano che il reddito di cittadinanza
era legge federale in Brasile fin dal 2004.
Questo per una semplice ragione:
la legge non era mai stata attuata.
Comunque, a quel tempo,
la vera risposta non è mai stata nella legge, ma nel diritto.
E non solo nel diritto dei cittadini brasiliani,
ma nel diritto universale di ogni umano
ad avere condizioni minime per vivere una vita dignitosa e libera.
Il diritto di tutti, senza nessuna discriminazione,
a un capitale di base.
Oppure, in altre parole,
un reddito sufficiente per soddisfare i bisogni primari,
senza nessun tipo di segregazione o di esigenze di qualche azienda,
a favore di ricambio nella comunità.
Dopo un anno di studi teorici, pratici e
con la biblioteca e ludoteca libera, in Paranapiacaba,
abbiamo lanciato con molto clamore, e in collaborazione con il potere pubblico,
un progetto per Paranapiacaba.
Molto presto abbiamo dovuto
spendere una considerevole quantità di tempo e denaro
tentando di mantenere la nostra parola
e cercando l'appoggio, e il finanziamento degli organismi pubblici e aziende,
ma sempre senza alcun successo.
Fu questo il momento critico in cui abbiamo preso la decisione
che avrebbe cambiato il corso di questa storia.
Ci siamo chiesti:
perché non prendiamo tutti questi soldi che vengono spesi inutilmente
ogni mese, cercando di convincere i politici di utilizzarli per pagare il reddito
in una comunità che abbia la dimensione della nostra tasca?
Naturalmente le risorse non potevano essere il solo criterio:
avevano bisogno di controllare, certo, il numero di variabili,
considerando le nostre limitazioni operative.
Ma abbiamo trovato un piccolo borgo rurale,
piuttosto isolato, di circa 100 persone.
E dopo il nostro primo incontro,
27 persone hanno accettato di partecipare al progetto.
Così, tranquillamente e in modo indipendente,
è stato realizzato, il 25 Ottobre del 2008,
il primo pagamento di un reddito di cittadinanza:
se non proprio il primo al mondo,
magari sarà stato il primo da cittadino a cittadino.
Oggi, tre anni dopo, ottantanove persone
ricevono 30 real al mese,
che rappresenta più o meno 12 euro al mese per persona.
Evidentemente, il progetto non consiste solo
nella distribuzione di denaro contante:
sappiamo che la povertà non è soltanto materiale,
ma anche culturale, e soprattutto politica.
Ecco perché intendiamo il reddito di cittadinanza
come parte di un capitale sociale, che ha bisogno di manifestarsi
in tutti gli altri aspetti dell'accesso alla società.
Economicamente, come reddito; culturalmente, come conoscenza;
e politicamente, come potere di decisione individuale e collettiva.
Cioè, come libertà, diritto e democrazia.
Secondo questa metodologia,
abbiamo progettato un'intera metodologia basata su tre pilastri:
La massima efficacia di trasparenza;
la pedagogia di ispirazione
e l'autodeterminazione per la democrazia diretta.
Con una grande efficienza e trasparenza,
esiste una trasformazione radicale tra le fonti di risorse:
tutte le risorse vanno per intero nelle mani dei partecipanti,
senza essere sprecate nel meccanismo o nei costi operativi del ReCivitas.
Nella pedagogia di ispirazione, ogni atto ha il significato del principio che essa esprime.
Il significato del reddito di cittadinanza non è trasmesso con parole,
lo trasmettiamo con atti che dopo sono rinforzati con il discorso.
In questo processo, teoria e pratica sono una cosa unica nello stesso spazio,
che non richiede una grande e costosa struttura di un ambiente pedagogico separato.
La pedagogia è fatta dentro il progetto,
e il proprio progetto è l'atto pedagogico.
Il terzo e ultimo fondamento è importante perché determina la eleggibilità
e l'autodeterminazione per democrazia diretta.
Significa che intendiamo la comunità come una rete.
in conformità al principio del reddito di cittadinanza,
non intendiamo le persone come un insieme di persone
in un particolare territorio e spazio geopolitico.
Le persone sono la comunità e la comunità
è determinata dalla rete sociale formata da queste persone.
Sono quindi le persone che determinano chi appartiene o no alla comunità,
eliminando costi e burocrazia, e guadagnando in autostima
quando determina lei propria la sua identità.
Questo è il principio della comunità per democrazia diretta.
Questo programma non è stato presentato per essere solo
per provocare un potere pubblico, ma per garantire un diritto di fatto,
il quale fino ad ora esisteva solo in teoria.
Ma più che limitarsi ad affermare una possibilità,
era necessario fornire prove empiriche da giustificare.
In questo consisteva la esperienza:
solo i risultati potevano rispondere
ad alcune domande circa il reddito di cittadinanza,
carico di pregiudizi o no, che non poteva restare senza risposta.
Le persone si sarebbero sentite o no sicure?
Non sarebbe meglio, più efficiente, dare solo ai bisognosi?
Così pochi soldi possono fare la differenza o no? E quale?
E con quale grado di libertà e anche di autodeterminazione,
può funzionare oggigiorno?
In altre parole, dopo essere stati condizionati tutta una vita
a comportarsi in conformità, con premi e punizioni,
saranno ancora in grado di sviluppare sentimenti di solidarietà,
e di convivere comunitariamente
in un sistema di mutua fiducia e di parità di diritti?
È questo l'obiettivo del progetto.
Per rispondere a queste domande
il progetto è stato aperto a studi e ricerche internazionali indipendenti,
cui ora daremo voce e spazio.
"L'argomento che i poveri non sanno spendere il loro reddito responsabilmente,
dando preferenza a programmi di trasferimento in natura,
o legato a condizionamenti determinati empiricamente, non regge
le famiglie molto povere, con poco accesso a lavori retribuiti,
hanno dimostrato di essere in grado di spendere denaro,
ricevuto nel consumo di prodotti di prima necessità,
salute ed istruzione per i membri della loro famiglia,
perfettamente in grado di prendere decisioni strategiche
per migliorare le condizioni di vita delle famiglie
a medio e lungo termine, attraverso modelli di spesa responsabile"
Alice Krozer - CEPAL ONU
In Quatinga Velho il più importante bene sociale
è il tempo dedicato agli altri al di fuori della famiglia,
senza essere pagato.
È superiore al lavoro medio pro-capite
in molti paesi sviluppati.
Il progetto di reddito di base a Quatinga Velho dimostra che
fornire un reddito di base può essere la soluzione più economica
ed un migliore assetto sul capitale sociale
e del bene comune di un luogo - Dr Alexander Dill,
Il valore di 30 reais del reddito di base di Quatinga Velho
è sufficiente ad aiutare le persone a soddisfare i bisogni materiali di base.
Sono soprattutto i bambini ad approfittare di questo beneficio.
Il progetto ReCivitias è riuscito,
con l'uso estremamente limitato di risorse finanziarie,
a ottenere significativi effetti sociali.
Va sottolineato l'impatto positivo sulla sodisfazione dei bisogni di base
e sulla qualità di vita dei partecipanti al progetto.
I risultati permettono di concludere che il reddito di base
ha contribuito allo sviluppo sostenibile a Quatinga Velho,
e gli effetti sono stati davvero convincenti,
soprattutto nel campo della garanzia dei bisogni fondamentali,
del miglioramento della qualità di vita e della formazione sociale. Matias Rudolph
Tuttavia, se la legge 10,835 non è stata applicata in Brasile,
un piccolo quartiere di Mogi Das Cruzes
entra nella storia come il primo luogo in Brasile
dov'è stato erogato il reddito di base per il cittadino.
In questa prospettiva, Santos Neto ritiene che il reddito di base
rompa la dipendenza dai programmi assistenziali,
evitando la distorsione del diritto universale
a un beneficio concessionale, cioè ad essere utilizzato per fini elettorali,
sia con la promessa di concessioni, sia con la paura del recesso,
senza interferire con l'esercizio libero e consapevole
del diritto di voto - Francesco Arrega.
Inoltre, dal reddito di base a Quatinga Velho,
abbiamo imparato che per evolvere dal semplice reddito di trasferimento
a reddito di base è necessario che il modello della gestione del programma
promuova i valori di cittadinanza.
L'eleggibilità, per mutuo riconoscimento in assemblea,
è un modello preferibile nelle piccole comunità, dov'è possibile il controllo sociale.
Inoltre, questo modello di determinazione
dell'eleggibilità in assemblee si avvicina alla emancipazione politica
perseguita dal reddito di base.
Proponiamo quindi che il municipio segua l'esempio del reddito di base a Quatinga Velho,
dando inizio a un primo progetto pilota, per esempio, di cinque anni.
Anthony Baert
Noi di ReCivitas, in un modo semplice e schematico,
concludiamo che il cambiamento risultato dal progetto pilota
di reddito di base a Quatinga Velho
liberano dall'incertezza per la propria sopravvivenza immediata.
Uno stato di vera libertà, che garantisce
non solo la fine delle proibizioni più primitive,
ma piuttosto l'emergere delle nuove prospettive di futuro.
Ed è per realizzare questo futuro
che abbiamo realizzato il progetto BigBank:
una banca sociale di reddito di base garantito
con l'obiettivo di fornire un reddito di base senza imposte,
rendendo sostenibile tutta la rete di protezione senza frontiere
in questo modello, le persone non contribuiscono con il loro capitale,
ma solo con l'interesse, o parte di esso,
per il pagamento del reddito di base,
per mezzo del fondo di sostenibilità nel terzo settore.
In questo momento,
siamo in una nuova fase di sperimentazione della banca:
il microcredito per il reddito di base è già in corso a Quatinga Velho,
e dal prossimo anno si aprirà, con un atto pubblico,
la replica del modello e l'affermazione dei moltiplicatori.
Queste nuove comunità saranno finanziate dal progetto BigBank.
Per determinare, o meglio per aprire la possibilità
di questo nuovo futuro, diamo voce al professor Tadashi Okanouchi:
"Il progetto è piccolo, ma dimostra
un enorme, incredibile potenziale alle possibilità di sviluppo
sociale ed economico della comunità locale.
Oserei dire che il progetto segna una svolta
nella storia del mondo della fame e miseria.
Perché nella località del progetto
abbiamo potuto finalmente trovare
la prova dell'efficacia di un metodo nuovo e semplice
per sradicare la povertà del mondo."